legislation basically this guy from
Schoolhouse Rock bill fun fact his last
name is Cosby and you can see why he
dropped it anyway in the lead-up to the
Democratic primaries we've heard a lot
of big promises about the fabulous bills
candidates will sign when they're
elected the best way to go forward in my
view is to a Medicare for All
single-payer program I have a proposal
to build about 3 million new housing
units my big idea is a freedom dividend
of $1,000 a month for every American
adults starting at age 18 my big ideas
baby bonds we need to have our
transportation system running on
electricity I'm gonna make sure that
happens
no jay Inslee you're not gonna make that
happen primarily because you dropped out
of the race two weeks ago possibly
because your whole campaign tactic of
drive by scooter shouting was at best a
little ahead of its time
the problem is as appealing as many of
those ideas sound non are likely to
happen even if a Democrat wins because
they'd have to go through the Senate and
you know this Senate is the country's
second most influential body after
Dwayne the rock Johnson's ladies and
gentlemen that man is 5 years older than
me and I know
whatever you're thinking now I know and
look the modern Senate is a giant non
functioning roadblock as any centers on
their way out will tell you the Senate
as an institution is in crisis the
people's business is not getting done
we're getting nothing done my friends
we're getting nothing done the United
States Senate is no longer the world's
greatest deliberative body and everybody
needs to quit saying it exactly senators
regularly do the thing that most people
can only dream of leave their jobs while
telling off everyone they worked with
this is no longer the town's greatest
Jamba Juice and everyone needs to quit
saying it you make it bad juice my
friends you make it bad juice the truth
is the Senate doesn't pass many major
laws these days you could argue the last
major social program passed into law was
a bomber care a decade ago and that low
level of production is largely thanks to
one incredibly annoying legislative tool
not actually this tool although he is
certainly at fault I'm referring to the
filibuster so that is what we're
actually going to look at tonight or if
you're watching this on YouTube this
morning or if you reach for the remote
the moment I've said the word filibuster
goodbye I completely understand a
filibuster is any tactic aimed at
blocking a measure by preventing it from
coming to a vote fund site go to the
word filibuster is derived from the
Dutch word for freebooter which
basically means pirates and I didn't
even know there were Dutch pirates but
I'd absolutely watch a movie about them
Avast me matey Sh batten down the
hatches and remember dead men tell no
tales
if you are at all aware of the
filibuster you probably know is that
thing where a senator stands and talks
endlessly it's often been presented in
TV and movies as a heroic act like when
Jimmy Stewart himself to exhaustion in
mr. Smith goes to Washington he was a
bad actor pretty bad back then he was
especially bad the thing is the thing is
that movie made the filibuster seem like
a good idea just like how the Wizard of
Oz made going on a trip with a furry a
vagrant and an axe wielding robots seem
like a good idea but in real life it's
only a good idea if you know them but
the modern filibuster is nothing like
the Jimmy Stewart version it's become an
overused tool of obstruction and in
practical terms it essentially means
that a simple majority of 51 votes isn't
nearly enough to pass legislation if you
don't get 60 votes for a bill it's dead
which means theoretically senators from
the 21 least populated states
representing just 11 percent of
Americans could overrule everyone else
which seems pretty extreme so to quote
everyone who's ever sat in a bathroom
stall with a 3-inch gap in the door why
on earth was it designed this way people
people often claim then it goes back to
the founding of the country it's an
argument that runs like this you may
wonder why the Senate has this 60 vote
rule when it's a straight majority rule
in the house well the answer is that the
founders meant it that way the Senate
was designed to be the cooling saucer
where the two parties were forced to
work together and hence that 60-vote
threshold okay so there's a few things
to know about that and the first thing
is that it is not true
there is nothing about a 60-vote
threshold for legislation in the
Constitution not
in the Federalist Papers nothing in
Jefferson's private letters and nothing
skillfully wrapped by Alexander Hamilton
to the delight of everyone within
earshot
in fact some historians say the
filibuster was created by mistake and
even then the first one didn't take
place until 1837 so it was categorically
not part of the founders original vision
it's like claiming the day Alexander
Graham Bell invented the telephone he
also sent the first dick pic no he did
that development came much later two
weeks later but but she is actually
right about that whole cooling saucer
idea that's a story that comes up
constantly and it goes like this the
Senate was created to be a cooling
saucer to the hot legislation that comes
from the house it is the cooling saucer
we all know the story the old metaphor
George Washington uses the house is the
cup of coffee where the coffee is very
hot the Senate is the saucer that you
pour the coffee into so it can cool all
the passions of the house first
never say cool like that ever again
but setting aside the argument that the
Senate should be more deliberative than
the house you might be wondering why on
earth would someone pour coffee into a
saucer
well in the 18th century people
apparently did exactly that they would
pour coffee out of their cup into a
saucer to let it cool and then drink it
directly from that which is clearly
ridiculous and it's obviously something
I wish I'd never learned because Thomas
Jefferson seems like a towering
historical figure until you imagine him
sipping out of a saucer like a
cat but it is true that the founders
wanted the Senate to be a counterweight
to the houses they achieve that though
by having fewer members who serve longer
terms six years not to and until 1913
not having them directly elected by the
people
so if keeping the filibuster is not
following the founders wishes why do we
still have it well some argue that it
preserved the Senate's ability to be a
bastion of debate as this senator
explained in 1952 the Senate of the
United States is the last open forum in
the world where the rights of all
minorities can be fully and freely and
completely debated and while
I would never and have never taken part
in a filibuster neither would I take
part in an effort which would which
would result in depriving any minority
group in this country from having their
cause fully discussed and fully debated
on the floor of the United States Senate
okay so first the Senate's reputation as
a haven of gentlemanly debate is at best
overblown in the 1800's Sanders has
pulled pistols on each other and at one
point a congressman used a metal topped
cane to beat Senator Charles Sumner
nearly to death so feeling nostalgic for
the Golden Age of the Senate is like
feeling nostalgic for 90s indie films
than actually watching chasing Amy
because set aside the notion that any
lesbian can be magically turned straight
if the right guy comes along
what extra offensive in hindsight is the
idea that that guy would be Ben Affleck
but that guy also touched on another
major argument for the filibuster there
that it protects minority rights
although it is worth noting that the
minority whose rights have historically
being protected by the filibuster are
the political minority who've often used
it to restrict the rights of racial
minorities the Senate's own website
calls the filibuster particularly useful
to southern senators who sought to block
civil rights legislation and it was used
most notably by Senator Strom Thurmond
just watch him announced his plans to
try and kill the Civil Rights Act of
1964 by subjecting it to endless debate
it will be the aim of our small band of
southern senators to make say that every
facet of this legislation is discussed
considered and expanded at great length
even indefinitely if necessary exactly
he just gave the game while he wanted to
debate it indefinitely his goal wasn't
to consider every aspect of the bill his
goal was to kill it he's like a
five-year-old saying I shall pull the
legs off this bug so that every facet of
it may be discussed and considered at
great length know that little psycho
just wants to watch a bug die
and Thurman's knew just how obstructing
the filibuster could be in 1957 he
stalled another civil rights bill by
speaking for a still record 24 hours and
18 minutes straight while according to
some accounts he had his aide wait in
the cloakroom with a pail so he could
relieve himself while still keeping a
foot on the Senate floor and it's almost
impressive to take a morally disgusting
act and somehow make it physically
disgusting - it's like if Hitler had
delivered all his speeches while
publicly clipping his toenails
now now modern filibusters actually no
longer can tame the David Blaine esque
feat of endurance element and that is
because in the 70s in the interests of
efficiency senators agreed to no longer
require talking filibusters you know in
the style of mr. Smith goes to
Washington or mr. Thurmond goes to the
bathroom in a bucket instead now if you
just signal your intent to filibuster
and have 41 votes on your side a bill is
doomed which is not to say that senators
don't still sometimes choose to stand in
Talk vows it's just that when they do
it's often a publicity stunt or a
protest like when Chris Murphy spoke for
15 hours to draw attention to gun
control or Rand Paul filibustered
Obama's nominee for CIA director for 13
hours pausing only to eat fun-sized
candy with spectacular incompetence
which had previously brought a challenge
in federal court to the legality of the
authorization to target our walk in
Yemen release the following statement
are you eating something so small that
badly I mean it didn't even present the
challenge of a regular candy bar we've
all gotten into the quad more of a
normal sized Milky Way and not being
able to get out until everything we know
and love is covered in caramel we've all
been there but that was fun sighs it
should have been easy
although I will say this at least Rand
Paul stayed on topic unlike when Ted
Cruz filibustered against Obamacare and
when you watch this remember the stated
argument for this tactic is it is
supposed to be a vital means of
facilitating a full and robust debate I
do not like green eggs and
I do not like them sam-i-am would you
like them in a house would you like them
with a mouse I do not like them in a
house I do not like them with a mouse I
do not like them here or there I do not
like them anywhere I do not like that
man Ted Cruz I do not like his part
right views I do not like his stupid
chin I do not like his smarmy grin I do
not like him with a beard I do not like
him
freshly shi'ite I do not like Ted Cruz
at all that man Ted Cruz can suck my
balls didn't need to do that and when
you combine the fact that it's now
easier to filibuster with the
increasingly partisan nature of the
Senate it's frankly no surprise that its
usage has skyrocketed if you look at the
number of cloture votes which is a good
way to measure filibuster use the number
during Eisenhower's term here was two
whereas in Obama's eight years here
there were 506 which kind of undercuts
the final argument made in favor of the
filibuster that encourages
bipartisanship
that if you have to get 60 votes to end
debate on a bill the parties would you
have to work together but the reality
there is that is simply not happening
thanks to the filibuster many pieces of
meaningful legislation some with
bipartisan support have died from the
manchin-toomey gun control bill to the
Paycheck Fairness Act to the public
option in Obamacare we have reached a
point where senators don't so much brag
about what they've passed as brag about
what they are going to obstruct just
watch Mitch McConnell promising a room
of supporters that the green New Deal
and Medicare for all won't even see a
vote if they ever end up in his chamber
[Music]
to make sure okay Mitch you really don't
have to tell me to think of you as the
grim reaper it's like if Donald Trump
said think of me as a bunch of trash
bags from a Cracker Barrel dumpster
brought to life by an ancient curse when
a clown a car alarm
I'm Way ahead of you there buddy I
already think of you that way so to
recap the main arguments in favor of the
filibuster we've always had it no we
haven't it enables debate no it doesn't
it protects minorities not the ones
you're thinking of it encourages
bipartisanship not even close it has
become so difficult to pass a law the
big issues of our day are now being
handled by other branches of the
government major issues from immigration
to climate change are being decided to
things like executive actions and court
rulings so why keep the filibuster some
presidential candidates including Pete
Buddha judge Steve Bullock and Elizabeth
Warren want to get rid of it but before
you get too excited about some of your
favorite Democrats and also Steve
Bullock calling for it to be abolished
you should know so has this guy we have
to get rid of what's called the
filibuster rule we have to and if we
don't the Republicans will never get
anything passed you're wasting your time
exactly and there is just nothing that
can make you question one of your
beliefs quite like Donald Trump
unexpectedly sharing it well point out
there are endless opinions that a person
can have inevitably a few of them will
overlap with Donald Trump's for example
he and I both enjoy a good hamburger we
don't we both think James Comey is a big
pasty goober it's true and neither of us
are willing to Google Tiffani Trump's
birthday we're not completely different
here now but the fact that Donald Trump
is in favor of ending the filibuster is
a good reminder of the serious risk here
the side you agree with won't always be
in power abolishing the filibuster would
make it easier for everyone to do things
including people you might not agree
with and there have been hard lessons in
this regard recently it used to be
possible to filibuster judicial
nominations that was rolled back even
for the Supreme Court and one
consequence was last year's 52-48
confirmation of justice
sourpuss J booths a lot so look this is
undeniably a gamble and you may well
feel that is just too risky but
personally I have come around to
thinking that it is a work a risk worth
taking
the Senate is supposed to address
America's problems and the filibuster is
making it basically impossible for them
to do that and someone suggested merely
reforming it maybe going back to forcing
senators to pay a physical price and
stand and talk for hours again but as we
have seen some senators are more than
happy to do that
even if they don't have to and do you
really want to hear more of Ted Cruz
creepily reading you bedtime stories or
what Rand Paul battled Phung sized candy
to a draw no no you don't so that is why
I'm arguing despite the risk that we
should get rid of the filibuster and
frankly what better way for me to do
that than with the exact kind of big
stupid speech that I hate so please come
with me as I filibuster the filibuster
and to be clear I'm not going to talk
for 15 hours one it's completely
unnecessary and two it sounds hard and
we only have a minute left of this show
so I'll just do the only parts of a
filibuster that anyone remembers anyway
here's the beginning part where I'm
lucid and on topic and I say the
filibuster has made the Senate
completely unable to perform its duties
and something has to be done my friends
something has to be done now let's jump
to the fun part where I somehow fail at
eating junk food which is why I've
bought this big plastic candy cane full
of M&Ms
how is this so difficult don't help me
don't help me I can do this on my own
it's harder than it looks and now let's
cut straight to the part where I make an
important point while also you're an
aiding into a bucket oh that's better
the point here is my friends the more
you learn about the filibuster the more
it appears to be a historical mistake
that's not serving us well today hold on
hold on hold on don't look at me nobody
look at me there she goes
and while it is good yes to give the
minority party a voice in the Senate it
should not come at the cost of getting
anything done and now let's jump forward
15 hours to my final exhausted points
because what I'm essentially saying here
is requiring bills to have 60 votes is
like pouring coffee out of a perfectly
good cup into a saucer and then lapping
it up like a cat sure people think it
was a good idea yes but at some point
someone needs to ask does this make
sense or is it actually incredibly
stupid that is our show thank
you so much for watching
my boys out too much
you
[Music]